so Donald Trump has again for the second
time in two weeks gone to a sporting
event in public and just been brutally
brutally booed this time even more than
last week it's been interesting to
observe in a few ways it's a story about
the twenty20 election in a sense it's a
story about Donald Trump's bubble that
he exists in and it's also a story about
media propaganda which we'll get to a
little bit later on in the segment so
let me catch you up last week Donald
Trump went to Game five of the major
league baseball world series he was
booed there were chants of lock him up
that broke out throughout the stadium
arguably it's less surprising at a
Washington DC baseball game even though
baseball's not a particularly left-wing
sport as an organization Washington DC
is quite left-wing it's not shocking
he'd get booed although people do go
from more conservative Virginia to the
games but Trump was visibly shocked by
the booing that was taking place last
week we played videos for you you can
see Trump grimacing you can see him
being popped out of the filter bubble
that he creates for himself at rallies
and at the White House with brown-nosing
suck-up Saul around him and then there
was a media propaganda story that came
following it because Fox News cut out
the booing from their reports about
Trump's visit and referred to it as
quote mixed reaction from the crowd so
that was last week lo and behold over
this weekend Donald Trump goes to a UFC
event in New York City at Madison Square
Garden UFC of course is a mixed martial
arts league and once again the booing
just absolutely brutal check it out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's another one of Trump making his
grand entrance
[Applause]
[Applause]
and maybe most brutally is the last one
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay I think you get it so once again
some references to this as a mixed
reaction and of course if you put 21,000
people in a stadium you're going to have
some magic lounge but it's a very
negative reaction overall to Donald
Trump now this is why this is so
interesting the UFC okay
Trump is friends with big Trump
supporter and UFC president Dana White
white spoke at the Republican National
Convention he's a big trumpet one would
expect UFC to be more Donald Trump's
crowd this is not some stereotype that
anyone who likes fighting is a trumpets
but different sports have different
crowds and to some degree even in New
York City you would expect a somewhat
friendlier to Trump crowd to be there at
a UFC event so this could be a signal
about 2020 it's definitely a signal
about Donald Trump's impeachment which
continues to grow in popularity but it's
also a story about media propaganda as
Fox News insisting once again that
people just loved Trump showing up there
check it out you know what isn't pretty
also UFC fights yeah like these guys are
fighting to take it all the way down the
president went to Madison Square Garden
last night watch Jorge MASMA doll take
on Nate Diaz the call was that the fight
was actually called after three rounds
because there's a cut for Diaz but the
president got a big reception you know
the media could say what they want about
it but this is a crowd that loves their
this is not a PC crowd right here this
is a crowd that appreciates the brawler
style of a brawler president who was
there in New York City City the belly
the beats to watch this fight or some
media that's actually saying that they
mostly heard boos this has become so
juvenile if you actually listen of IDEO
in the audio there clearly were the who
are child Cheers so Pete Hedgepeth or
hatch bath or Ike you have a trouble
saying his name whatever his name is
he's correct in that this is not a PC
crowd and yet they still were mostly
disgusted by Donald Trump appearing
there you definitely shouldn't trust the
people who seven days ago edited out the
booing at the World Series to tell you
if there was booing at the UFC the
videos I think tell you everything you
need to know but what Donald Trump
really needs to be doing is just go to a
NASCAR race go to a NASCAR race in
North Carolina or Georgia or something
like that and if they boo him there he's
really in trouble for 2020
I don't know that Donald Trump has any
interest in going to NASCAR but that
would be my recommendation to him make
sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show
clips of the show
pull questions behind-the-scenes
pictures including of the main studio of
Pat's lair of the entire thing and while
you're there on your Instagram app
follow me as well at David Pakman we
will take a quick break and a lot more
coming up on this Monday show for you
today
the holidays are almost here and that
means you might be looking for some
gifts what better gift to give the guy
in your life than a stylish shirt that
actually fits properly
unlike most brands on Tucket shirts are
designed to be worn untucked they fall
at that just right length no matter his
size I have had such a great experience
with my untucked shirts I frequently
wear untucked shirts on the show when I
wear them in my normal life and people
can see how long they are they say that
shirt fits perfectly where did you get
it there are more than 50 fit
combinations the shirts look great on
tall short slim athletic guys of all
ages you can choose from styles like
wrinkle free button downs super soft
flannels they've got outerwear much more
you can find your favorite untuck it
style online or check out one of their
80 brick-and-mortar stores whether
you're shopping for the perfect holiday
gift or you just want to craft a relaxed
and smart style of your own untuck it is
the way to go
goto untuck it calm and use the coupon
code Pakman for 20% off it check out
that's un tu CK I T dot-com promo code
PA KMA on to save 20% off